hallo leute wir begrüßen euch heute aus
mexiko city und wir sind hier am central
engpass extraklasse und tomaten elite
doppel die technik kann das ja nicht
und weil wir an einer sprachschule sind
drehen wir ein neues video für euch
heute geht es um das thema um zu
wir zeigen euch wie man setze im
deutschen bildet mit um zu los gehts
jahre spielt gitarre um geld zu
verdienen
[Musik]
da lila putzt ihre brille um die tafel
besser zu sehen
israel zeigen seinen studentenausweis um
in die schule zu kommen
die bahn fährt jeden morgen mit dem
fahrrad um zur schule zu kommen
sie tanzen um spaß zu haben
kenia zieht sich eine jacke an um nicht
zu frieren
daniel steigt auf einen stuhl um den
beamer an zu machen
christian liest ein buch um neue
vokabeln zu lernen
sie üben o tannebaum um nächste woche
beim weihnachtsfest zu singen da sie
haben ein plakat aufgehangen um werbung
für unseren workshops zu machen
sie rennen um nicht zu spät zum
unterricht zu kommen
oskar ist im unterricht um nicht zu
verhungern
die studenten geben ihre hausaufgaben ab
um einen stempel zu bekommen
man lernt deutsch um einen master in
deutschland zu machen
klavier guckt auf sein handy um die
nachrichten zu lesen
jetzt könnt ihr dieses ganze thema noch
selbst üben und zwar in unserer apps
dort könnt ihr eigene sätze bilden mit
um zu ihr könnt dabei eure aussprache
trainieren und die aussprache mit
deutschen muttersprachlern vergleichen
ihr könnt auch verschiedene übungen
machen und das ganze wird euch dabei
helfen selber diese satzstruktur besser
zu bilden
danke schön dass ihr heute zugeschaltet
habt und wir freuen uns auf bald